this is the Dave Ramsey show that's how
we roll here people we're gonna tell you
the truth and it's always weird let me
just tell you what normal is 70% of
Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck the number one cause of divorce
in North America today's money fights
and money problems the typical student
goes to the student goes to school and
comes out with thirty to a hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt
most of you are walking around with an
average of ten to twenty five thousand
dollars in credit card debt and you have
car payments and you think car payments
are a way of life you'll never have a
car without a car payment and you live
your life and you work your whole life
and you have millions of dollars of
income come into your house throughout
your working life and flow back out and
you have nothing to show for it
your ATAR broke financially your freakin
rat in a wheel normal normal is broke
looking good impressing people at the
stoplight and all your broke friends
think you're okay because you're just as
normal as they are she won't be normal
it's unusual to be wealthy behaviors
decisions and habits and character
traits caused you to build wealth and if
wealth is unusual than unusual behaviors
habits and character traits are
necessary for you to become wealthy you
can be normal normal is pretty easy and
you can look like you're having a good
life but you'll be stressed and you have
no money I mean it's ridiculous you guys
the amount of money you make in your
working lifetime and you get to
retirement and say I sure hope the
government which is well known for its
ability to handle money will take care
of me that's just straight-up stupid
whatever everyone else is doing with
money you need to run the other way get
out of debt house and everything quit
borrowing money start investing steadily
constantly consistently
cut up your credit cards completely all
of them that's not hard you guys this is
how it's done be weird